what's your favorite goal if I could
relive a moment would it be the bicycle
kick against England yes because it was
I tell you why because of many reasons
because the goal is amazing I mean the
goal for
me not because it's me not because of my
ego who would do that thing I don't see
many players do that thing because many
players in that situation we were
winning 3-2 it was the last minutes we
take down the ball and waste time
because you want to win the game
obviously but when I saw the moment I
said heart was a goalie and I said I
will fool him now when I saw him run out
I will pretend to go forward towards him
then I will back off because I know by
experience you go towards somebody he
will just head it and it will go far out
but I will do opposite I will pretend to
go with him so a certain point you will
see me slow break slow down then go back
then it was all about where the ball
comes because I don't know and then I
took it instinctly from there like turn
around and as a striker you know where
your goal is you don't need to see the
goal you can put me in every angle on
the field I will know where the goal is
because so as soon as you hit the ball
with the bicycle kick you knew it was
going I knew already where the goal was
the let's say and did you know when you
hit it it was going in yes you could
feel it yes the only tricky was here I
needed to change my angle body angle
versus the goal so I could not let's say
bicycle kick so if you want to kick it
straight with a bicycle kick it goes
straight back so the only thing I needed
was to change my angle body where the
goal is and I knew where the goal is so
I just needed to change and I know the
goal is there and now just hit the ball
and I was focused on hitting the ball
because that was the most important how
I fell or not I didn't care you you said
you have stopped outside in the treat by
some Paparazzi and asked was Cristiano
Ronaldo's bicycle kick goal the best
you've seen and you said yes do you
still think that I was being sarcastic
oh you were yes you meant your which not
many understood but I'm not there to
explain that because if you cannot read
my mind it's not my fault so you think
yours was better 100% 100% I said in an
interview later you should try it from
40 m it's a big difference even if his
was beautiful but this was from 40 m is
it is it I've asked I actually asked him
the same question but when you score a
goal like that is it better than
sex I mean my game that in that game was
crazy because why it was that's what I
wanted to come that's not the answer
yeah but you have to see the whole
package the goal no sex is better come
on my friend sex is better we don't even
go there sex is 10 times better not one
time better 100% is this in case Helena
is watching this yeah no no no no no no
no no sex is better whoever thinks
different he has a problem with his sex
life he should get help but uh I
wouldn't know I never scored a 40 yard
bicycle kick no you get a lot of
adrenaline so after the goal I saw
wilbeck I think he was the striker and I
took off the shirt and I said enjoy
because something like this he will
never see again and he was watching me
so you see even in that moment I get
anger out instead of just en Joy so I
throw out and I look at him actually I
was rude but I don't know why I was rude
to him I needed to find OB so I said
enjoy because you will never enjoy this
again but he hasn't done nothing for me
but that's me looking for it's your
natural fighting Instinct so he not
personal against him so that's me and he
was watching me he didn't understand
nothing because I have nothing happened
but the game what the goal is why the
goal is most beautiful because of
England because before I came to
England they talk bad because if you
haven't played in Premier League you're
not good enough that's the mentality
here which I respect because they want
to see you challenge your game here and
then during the game they they were
calling me the diva they were calling me
a fake Carol the fans are doing yeah the
fans so it was going on and before that
the media was writing I never score
against England teams in Champions
League I always fail against the english
team so everything this was going around
my head so that's why I say it's a whole
package I score four goals and I don't
know I think F Baston or I have the
record against
England and this was a whole package
because of all the I got that is the
most beautiful goal and it's a goal
England will always remember for the
rest of their life that's true so that
that's why it feels better I personally
think you've scored a better goal okay
and I'm going to tell you I had many
goals that is crazy I'm going to tell
you the one I think is your greatest
goal see what you think this was for ax
against NAC braa yeah where you
basically terrorized their entire team
the whole team you go through the whole
team was and then you score that to me
as a because the bicycle kick is a
brilliantly executed goal no question
but the way you tormented that team for
that goal was really extraordinary yeah
that
was that
was was nasty because often the
beautiful goals is the the what the the
goals you will remember is the goals you
cannot repeat that is often I mean a
bicycle kick from 40 m maybe you can
repeat maybe you can repeat the drib
because I saw I saw Messi I saw I saw
Maradona how field doing against England
doing these crazy goals and uh it was a
crazy goal but it this is Instinct these
things happen at the moment this is
nothing you plan this is nothing you you
you try to do what's the best goal
you've seen scored by somebody
else the one you wish you'd
scored I think my goals not for my ego
my goals are crazy
goals crazy because I'm 197 and I'm 97
kilos so it's not normal to score these
goals if you have this size but a goal I
would like to score I mean I like the
zidan goal in the final when he with the
left foot because it's difficult to
repeat and those goals that you cannot
repeat is the most goals you will
remember but I have top top from top 10
I have maybe five
goals